alright sorry for the delay on this
video but as promised here we go the
world's end so the world end is done by
Edgar Wright his guy brought a Shaun of
the Dead and Hot Fuzz same kind of
humour now it's the World's End as you
would expect the movie has Simon Pegg
and Nick Frost but he has a few other
friends also it has Martin Freeman Bilbo
Baggins and Watson from the BBC Sherlock
dudes awesome and he's in the movie this
is a very different role from Simon Pegg
Simon Pegg was like the alpha male of
his childhood group of friends everyone
else has grown up and moved on but he
wants to live in the past he's this
really narcissistic stubborn egotistical
maniac he's like Greg house but less
successful so he regroups with his
childhood friends that I'll go to the
home town that they grew up in and
they're gonna finally conquer the
challenge that they never got to conquer
his children and really none of them
give a to conquer now except for
Simon Pegg because like I said man child
dude's gotta have priorities they're
gonna barhop 12 bars 12 pubs in one
night the last one is called the World's
End the quirky British comedies
happening and I'm enjoying it yours of
Benny Hill and Red Dwarf as a child have
honed my skills into enjoying British
comedy and then like in from dusk till
dawn unexpectedly the movie takes a
total flip a total turn and now they're
fighting robots that aren't actually
robots but the robots but they're not
robot but priorities they still gotta
conquer the challenge I mean come on why
would you stop now Simon Pegg first of
all I'm gonna say this right here this
is his best role I've ever seen him in
it's just such a different role for him
I've never seen him in a role like this
he was just really fast talking
time and you can tell he was really fun
as a kid but now he's just like dude
you're almost 40 you got to stop being
like that rest assured if I lose
everything in my life and I just burn
out I'll probably end up being like him
luckily I still have things to live for
so that's cool
he annoys you in that loveable kind of
way you can tell everyone there who's
annoyed with him you're like I'd be
annoyed if I was there too but I'm just
I'm an outsider looking in and he's just
cracking me up right now I think more
movies should have the stubborn
narcissist be the main character that's
what's lacking in cinema today thank you
Edgar Wright for giving us that and the
movie had really good and exciting fight
sequences I was perplexed for a little
bit of the movie I was like why do all
the robots fight like this and try to
grab your face but into the movie I was
like okay I get it and it did make sense
at first though I was just like I don't
think British robots know how to fight
and although all the
friends were really good in the movie
Simon Pegg and Nick Frost or definitely
the contrast that you're looking at
there the duo and all the other movies
so in this one you're like okay you're
gonna make this movie and they totally
do and you're even rooting for Simon
Pegg he has a really good monologue at
the end of this movie not gonna spoil
the movie for you he's talking about
he's like this is our time our time down
here Goonies never say die he doesn't
say that but you know what a good
monologues a good monologue I can say
these Edgar Wright movies are all very
similar in a really good way the more I
think about it the more I really like it
so I had a good time with the worlds and
had really good characters really good
moments really great humor Simon Pegg
kills it in the movie does have British
pacing which might throw some people off
but for me I'm gonna buy the World's End
on blu-ray a movie that's just there to
be fun but is also smarts really tough
mix and this movie does it well right so
Shaun of the Dead Hot Fuzz and the
World's End which one do you prefer
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you liked what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more